Here's another example, how you can trade market structure shifts using the autofold training strategy. You can see that we were making higher high, higher low, higher high, higher high, higher high, higher high. And then we made this move, which broke this level. There you go, it broke this level. This low.
high high and then price broke this higher low. So that is considered to be has
market structure shift. And then what you want to do remember you want to draw
your Fibonacci tool not necessarily but if you just want to see where are that
zones right you want to draw out the Fibonacci from the top to the bottom and
and then you want to choose the extreme zone.
Okay.
So as you can see,
we got an autoblock
right around here.
What are autoblocks?
The first candle that create imbalance.
You can see first, second, third.
There's some gap here as well.
And basically, you do not.
Okay.
So, yeah.
So basically you can see you would have entered
right around here put your stop loss right above that level and kaboom very easy guys
and you would have taken your take profit at this level which is another liquidity pool and before
price went up you can see price created these relative equal highs
okay this is liquidity this is basically a resistance level if that makes sense okay
So make sure you identify
Liquidity before taking these entries if there's no liquidity
You're going to lose. Okay, if there's no liquidity what's probably gonna do?
It's just gonna go up it will not respect your level because there's no reason for it to respect it. Okay
So you can see price
Broke structure
There was a market structure shift then price
engineer liquidity and then it went all the way up to the extreme zone of that
move that broke the market structure. If that makes sense. So this was another
example how you can use each and everything together to trade. So I'll give
you now examples for the long positions.